Bitte schön.
Hallo. Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Hier ist mein Name. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistant als Tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen heute das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne. Natürlich. Deswegen bin ich ja hier.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und bevor ich mit der agenziellen Anamnese anfange,
will ich kurz Ihre persönliche Daten fragen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Wie bitte? Was möchten Sie?
Ich will Ihre persönliche Daten fragen.
Ah, okay, bitte schön.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Yvonne Denzal.
Denzal. Denzal.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen langsam stöpieren?
Ja, natürlich.
Dora Emil Nordpol, Sieg Fritanto Hans Ludwig Denzal.
Okay.
Herr Denzal, wie schweißen Sie?
Die Frau ist eine Frau.
Ja, die Frau Denzal, wie schweißen Sie?
Wie bitte? Was möchten Sie wissen?
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ah, ich glaube ich bin 95 kg ungefähr.
Größe ist 1,69 m.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Das wollte ich erst mal fragen.
Wie heißen Sie?
48 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie geboren?
Genau.
Wo mein Geburtstatus ist, neu je.
Das ist der 24. März 1989.
80?
Nein.
86.
76.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich war schon vor 2 Tagen schon mal da.
Aber Bauchschmerzen, die nicht besser werden.
Bauchschmerzen nicht besser werden.
Sie wollen schon mal hier ein?
Vor 2 Tagen, da habe ich Schmerzmedikamente bekommen.
Da hat mich wieder eine Hause geschickt.
Aber die Schmerzen sind nicht besser geworden.
Im Gegenteil, es wird noch schlimmer.
Sie haben seit 2 Tagen diese Beschwerden, oder?
Nein, das habe ich schon seit über 1 Woche.
Über 1 Woche?
Wir haben Ihre Beschwerden begonnen.
Sind Sie langsam oder plösslich aufgetan?
Wir haben so in Bereich des Magens angefangen.
Am Anfang war das so ein bisschen leicht drinnen.
Da habe ich immer wieder Krämpfe bekommen.
Und das Strahl so ein bisschen im Oberbauch aus.
Erst mal, wo sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten?
Können Sie noch mal sagen, im Bauchbereich?
Bereich des Magens, da oben in der Mitte.
Und oben auch, warum?
Ja, genau.
Und Ihre Schmerzen strellen nach oben bis zum Gehäten?
Manchmal nach oben, manchmal so ein bisschen nach rechts.
Haben Sie noch etwas ungewöhnliches beim Weg?
Haben Sie vielleicht ein Endegefühl?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Aber ich habe mehrfach erbrochen.
Seit gestern habe ich auch ein bisschen Durchfall.
Wie sind Ihre Schmerzen, sind sie erhörig oder durchkant?
Das ist eher politisch, als es kommt und geht immer wieder.
Dann ist es mal ziemlich stark und dann wird es ein bisschen besser.
Aber ganz weg gehen Sie nicht.
Wie hat sich Ihr Schmerz mit der Zeit verändert?
Sind sie schlimmer geworden?
Ja, das heißt, die Krämpfe werden schlimmer.
Das ist ein bisschen besser geworden, aber ist immer noch da.
Gibt es Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen?
Es ist immer da, ich kann nicht sagen.
Klar, ich kann kaum essen, weil es da noch mehr retut, wenn ich esse.
Ich habe auch keinen Appetit, ich zeige 3-4 Tage.
Ich habe noch keine Ahnung, aber ich habe noch keine Ahnung.
Eine Ahnung, dass ich sie nicht mehr schmerzt.
Gibt es etwas, dass Ihre Schmerzen lentert oder verstärkt?
Ich habe eine Valgin-Tablette genommen.
Damit wird es ein bisschen besser, aber ganz weg geht es nicht weg.
Ich will nochmal Ihre Information übergehen.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie Oberbauchschmerzen haben.
Sie stellen nach oben und rechts Oberbauch auf.
und recht oberwoch
und ihre Schmerzen sind immer schlimmer geworden
und nach dem Essen verstärkt ihre Schmerzen sich
bzw ich kann jetzt auch seit 2 Tagen kaum etwas essen, also ganz schlecht
ja, abgesehen von Inapetens, haben sie Fieber oder Störflos bemerkt?
Nein
okay, sie haben Durchfall und haben sie Überkalt?
ja, ja, Überkalt ist auch immer regelmäßig, ja
haben sie Probleme mit dem, beim Wasserlassen oder Sturrgang?
Probleme habe ich nicht, aber wie gesagt der Sturrgang ist etwas weich geworden, wie ein Durchfall
und die Farbe ist ein bisschen komisch, also es ist eher ein bisschen hell geworden
und der Urin ist dafür etwas dunkler
und was mir so ein bisschen auffällt ist, dass die Farbe der Haut so ein bisschen komisch gelbt wird
ja, haben sie Lust?
Nein
haben sie Yukrais?
haben sie in der Leicester-Site abgenommen oder nicht?
Nein, nein, nein
okay
nun habe ich ein paar Frage bezüglich der Vorgeschichte
gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen in der Vorgeschichte von den ich wissen sollte?
Ja, ja, ich habe eine bekannte Depression
und nehme seit vielen Jahren Medikamente
nochmal bitte, was haben Sie, ich könnte nicht akustisch nicht gut hören
Nein, ich habe Depressionen
Depressionen haben Sie?
Ja, ja
und nehmen Sie dafür Medikamente ein?
Ja, ja, ich nehme jetzt schon seit vielen Jahren Medikamente
Was für Medikamente ist das denn?
Oh, ich weiß es nicht mehr, dann muss ich mal nochmal nachgucken
ich habe die Namen nicht im Kopf
dann Sie wissen wie viel Milgramm Sie ausnehmen können
kann ich nicht sagen, aber ich kann das noch dringend lassen
ich habe eine Medikamentenliste, da steht es drauf ja
Ah, sehr gut, dann gucke ich nach
und abgesehen von Depressionen
Was für Beschwerte haben Sie in der Erkrankung in der Vorgeschichte?
Also ich habe ansonsten an der Erkrankung einen Diabetes
seit vielen Jahren, ich nehme da Insulin
und ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck
da habe ich auch Tabletten
Für Diabetes medikates lasse ich nicht mehr
aber wie gesagt, ich kann mit den Namen der Tabletten nicht merken
da kann ich Ihnen nachher eine
Sie haben eine Medikamentenliste dabei?
Ja, ich habe das im Auto vergessen, kann ich Ihnen nachher geben
Okay
dann hatte ich eine Kooperation am Knie
Was für O-K-N-
am Knie
und das ist ungefähr fünf Jahre her
da habe ich vom Kreuzbandriss gehabt
nochmal bitte
Kreuzbandriss
und was für
Wann wurden Sie operiert?
Bitte?
Ja, habe ich gesagt, vor fünf Jahren ungefähr
Am Knie
Abgesehen von Knie-OP
und habe ich keine Operationen
Habt ihr allergien, wie gesagt, Medikamenten?
Ja, ich habe allergien gegen Penicillin
und gegen Aspirin
Okay
Frau Denzal, haben Sie Medikamentenbeschwerden?
Nein, ich bin schon seit einigen Jahren in der Menopause
Frau Denzal, rauchen Sie?
Nein
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich muss diese Frage stellen
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein
Trägen Sie Sport?
Nun, ich will fragen,
bis ich Ihre Familie vorgeschichtet habe
Leiden Ihr Vater, Ihre Mutter, Ihre Schwester
an chronischen Erkrankungen oder wichtige Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich bin der einzigende Familie, der
so viele Erkrankungen hat
Ja
Ich habe diese Frage gestellt,
aber lebt Ihr Eltern noch?
Nein
Wann sind Sie gestorben?
Das war hier nicht mehr, ich glaube, mein Vater
hatte einen Herz infarkt
und meine Mutter bekam leider einen Schlaganfall
Schlaganfall?
Frau Denzal, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Im Moment arbeite ich nicht
früher war ich im Kindergarten eine Erzieherin
Okay
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein
Ich habe eine Tochter
Ich war verheiratet, aber wir haben uns vor 10 Jahren getrennt
Sie haben eine Tochter?
Ja
Wollen Sie alleine oder mit einer Tochter?
Nein, mit meiner Tochter zusammen
Frau Denzal, gibt es jemanden,
mit den Notarztationen kontaktieren können?
Ja, natürlich, sie können meine Tochter anrufen
und kontaktieren
Ich habe eine wichtige Frage gestellt
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie etwas haben,
damit die Schmerzen besser werden?
Ich bin jetzt schon das zweite, dritte Mal hier
Es muss ja etwas sein
Es muss ja etwas geben, etwas hilft
Also bitte helfen Sie mir noch
Ich möchte Sie sagen, dass ich nicht so wenig sagen kann
aber nach der Rücksprache mit meiner Oberarzt
werde ich gleich wieder da
und benötigte Informationen werde ich Ihnen sagen
Okay, danke schön
Wir machen jetzt eine Blutabnahme
Ja, in der Körper-Parlige-Untersuchung
werde ich Ihre Lungen und Ihr Herz abhören
Die Lunge ist gut, Herz ist gut
Wenn Sie am Bauch abdrücken, hat sie Oberbauchschmerzen
aber sie hat auch sehr starke Schmerzen im Rechten
Oberbauch
Ich sage Ihnen jetzt die Ergebnisse von den Untersuchungen
Im Ultraschalen, so eine Abdomen
sehen Sie eine große Gallenblase
mit vielen Steinen
Sie sehen den Gallengang sehr erweitert
auf fast 2 cm
Sie sehen viel Luft im Darm
die nähern Sie in Ordnung
Sie haben eine hohe CRP von 150
Sie haben eine Blutbild mit leichter Leuchte
Zutose, Sie haben ein Kreer von 1,4
eine GFR von 50
Sie haben erhöhte Leberwerte
GeoT, GPT, GammaGT sind dreistellig
300, 200 und 250
Sie haben ein leicht erhöhtes Bilirubin
Reicht, ich denke
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe zwei Fragen
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein
Hat die Beschwerden Schmerzen
nach einem fertigen Essen aufgetreten?
Nein, das fing plötzlich an
Das ist zunehmend schlecht
Das war es, danke
Noch andere?
Nein, keine Fragen, alles gut für mich
Ich habe noch eine Frage
Haben Sie alle Infungen gehabt?
Nein, meine Hausarztin hat alles gemacht
Ich habe noch eine Frage
Ihre Kindheitinfungen auch?
Ich glaube schon, meine Hausarztin hat gesagt, die Infungen sind alle komplett
Letzte Frage
Haben Sie eine Ausstrauung der Schmerzen im Rechtsschulter?
Nein, im Bauchbereich
Danke, alles gut
Schmerzintestät, Sie haben gesagt, der ist starker Schmerzen
Aber die Frage ist nicht der Fall
Schmerzintestät
Wie stark ist der Schmerz?
Auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10
Wobei 1 ist der leichter Schmerz
und 10 ist der starker Schmerz
Ich würde sagen, dass es unterschiedlich ist zwischen 6 und 8
Sie haben gesagt, der Haut
ist gelbisch geworden
und Augen
Sie sind auch etwas gelb
Wir haben einen Crowdband-Ritz-OP gemacht
durch oder links?
Links
Ihre Vater ist gegen
einen Herzinfarkt gestorben
Wie alt war er?
75, mein Vater war
meine Mutter war ungefähr 70
Waren Sie in nächster Zeit im Ausland?
Ich nein
Sie haben alle Infungen geimpft
aber ich würde gerne wissen, Hepatitis A und B
Das weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor
Da muss ich mal in den Impfpass reingucken
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben einen Neuallgen
Wie viele Mal?
Am Tag 3-4 Mal
Sie haben berichtet
Wie sieht die Übelkeit aus?
Es kommt mit der Übelkeit
das Erbrechen
Manchmal ist es grün, weil ich Geld habe
Sie haben Blut bemerkt?
Blut war ich dabei, bisher noch nicht
Das war meine Frage
Dann machen wir mal die Übergabe
Können wir als erstes mal anfangen
Ich habe eine Patientin bekommen
Es geht um Frau Den Sal
Sie ist 48 Jahre alt
95 kg schwer und 1,69 m groß
Frau Den Sal hat sich
in der Erbrechenung
eine Erbrechung von
Schmerzen vorgestellt
Die Schmerzen sind in den letzten 2 Tagen
schlimmer geworden
Nachdem Essen verschlimmert sich
die Erbrechenung von
Schmerzen
und die Erbrechenung von
hat sich seit 1 Woche
nachdem Essen verschlimmert sich
die Schmerzen
und für diese Schmerzen
berichtet Frau Den Sal, dass sie
Nevalgin eingenommen haben
aber das
leistet nur eine kleine Linderung
auf einer Schmerzklau
würden die Schmerzen bei 6
und 8
wurden für
am Ende viel eingeschaltet
und dann
Schmerzintestat bei 6
auf einer Schmerzklau
wurden die Schmerzen bei 6
und 8 liegen
als Beglebssymptome
wurden
viele von Erbrechen
Durchfall und Überkeit beschrieben
und hier ist
gebliefe Haut aufgefallen
Sie hat einen Ektarus oder?
Sie hat Ektarus
und Sturgang
als erstes
Sturgang sei als erstes her
dann
ja, dann hat
die Patientin
durch die Ruhin hinzu
und sie leidet unter Inapetanz
seit 3 Tagen
Anvorerkrankungen sind
Depressionen seit vielen Jahren
und Diabetes Melitus
und Bluthochdruck
Aber
Medikamentale haben sie
eine Medikamentale dabei
aber sie werden
diese Medikamentale nachher bezogen
Anvorerkrankungen
eine Europäische Linke
für 5 Jahre
das war Crois Bantris
operiert wurde
und Allergien
gegen Penicillin und Aspirin
bekannte Allergien
Sie ist nicht raucherin
trinkt keine Alkohol
Genusmital nimmt keine Drogen ein
macht keinen Sport
in Familienanamnese
fanden sie beim Vater
mit dem Akkord Infarctus
und bei der Mutta Apopleksi
ja
Sie ist gerade arbeitlos
aber früher war sie Erzieherin
Sie hat eine Tochter, lebt mit ihrer Tochter
und sie hatte gesagt
in Notar-Situationen können wir mit ihrer Tochter
in Kontakt kommen
haben wir Fieber gefragt oder?
Hat sie gefragt, ja
wir haben keine
und Schlafprobleme wurden verweigert
gewisse Anderungen wurden verweigert
verneint
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstheorose?
Verdachtstheorose lautet
Akkord-Koledokulitis
die differenzialen Diagnose
können wir
Koledokulitis
in normalen Sagesen
in Betrag kommen
und vielleicht
als Lokalisation morbus Crohn
können wir vielleicht denken
vielleicht, ungewöhnlich dass es so spät kommt
aber möglich
nicht möglich, also Urkutschperforation
können wir auch Urkutschperforation
zum Beispiel
Was kann es noch sein?
Perfora
Hepatische und Postepatische
gibt es und deswegen
denken wir diese
Was denken wir jetzt?
Hepatische oder Postepatische
Akkord-Pankretitis auch kann in Betrag kommen
Das ist doch das erste Wunderer an Denken
Pankretitis natürlich auch, Pankretitis muss man denken
Ja, aber ich habe einen Teil vor mich
Schmerzen gewartet
Nicht muss, manchmal
Nicht immer
Ein Pankretas kann genommen, daran muss man natürlich auch denken
klar
Die Pase haben sie nicht gefragt, die Pase war nur ganz leicht
Ich konnte die Laberverte nicht hören
aber ich wollte nicht unterbrechen
150 CRP
Die andere auch
Die waren hoch, also die Laberverte waren hoch
Okay, sehr gut
Ich hatte so eine Patientin die ist heute gekommen
Die hat auch sehr langsam gesprochen
Deswegen haben sie gemerkt, ich bin heute sehr langsam
nicht weil ich jetzt müde bin, sondern weil die Patientin auch
lange Jahre schon Depressionen hat
und die hat immer ganz langsam gesprochen
Das war auch ziemlich aufhrenig
Ich habe dann einen Ultraschall gemacht
und die hatte wirklich so einen dicken DHC
Und natürlich so einen dicken DHC
Wir haben gleich ins Krankenhaus geschickt
Ich weiß nicht, was ausgespielt ist
Aber sie hat eben Labo in Zündungszeichen
und das spricht schon für eine Code Dojo
Tschüss, Toletiersis
Haben Sie mir gesagt, dass die
Lipase und Romilaswerte erhöht sind?
Ganz leicht, ja
Man muss sich an Pankreas denken
Warum hat sie einen erweiterten Gallengang?
Das kann natürlich auch an einem Pankreas Kopf
Karzinomen liegen, klar
Kohlenkarzinomen, eventuell aber weniger
Aber die braucht eine Magenspiegel
Aber keine, wie symptomatisch die Fieber
nach Schreien, jewisch, verlos, keine
Deswegen erst mal Toletiersis
Natürlich, das ist unsere Arbeitsterechnung
Das wird wahrscheinlich ein CT
in einem Krankenhaus brauchen, eine CT-Abdomen
Aber denieren wir, der war schlecht
Vielleicht macht man auch gleich einen MRT oder ein ERCP
Aber man wird halt schauen, was ist die Ursache dafür
Aber sie war sehr komisch im Verhalten
Für die PCP
Diese Information ist sehr wichtig
Die Pencil und Aspirin aller Dinge
Deswegen müssen wir fragen
Wie äußert die sich?
Und diese Patienten
braucht Antibiotika und Analgetika
Deswegen ist diese Information sehr wichtig
Das stimmt, genau, deswegen habe ich es gesagt
Peki,
Therapie, keine türkische
Während der funktioniert
Aufseisen, Lauf und Tezigen müssen wir nur Deutsch sprechen
Ich bin Modellator, haca
Ich darf das dir, ne?
Therapie
Was machst du?
Du bist jetzt ein Doktor, du musst jetzt Patientin behandeln
Ach ja, ich bin ein Patientin
Ich bin ein Patientin, ich bin ein Patientin
Du musst jetzt Patientin behandeln
Ich würde für diese Patientin
erstmals ein Schmerzmittel geben
Nein, erst mal
Anflüssigkeit zu Fuhr und Elektrolyzgabe
Nachdem Schmerzmittelgabe
Und hinterher erfolgt
eine Antischaepasmolytikung
Vielleicht, das könnte für diese Patientin hilfreich sein
Und
für Antibiotika
Natürlich Antibiotika
Warum Antibiotika?
Weil
Serip und Infektionswerte
waren hoch bei dieser Patientin
Okay, welche Antibiotika
Geht es?
Ja, Herr Kollege, diese Frage
hat im Düsseldorf gestärkt
Wo sind die Gastroenterologen hier unter uns?
Aber diese Frage
ist der dritte Generation
Was?
Was bedeutet dritte Generation?
Im Düsseldorf ist die dritte Generation
Das ist die dritte Generation
Es ist die dritte Generation
Was bedeutet dritte Generation?
Das ist der dritte Generation
Aus einer
eine GFR50, wenn möglich würde man eher einen MRT dann vorschlagen.
Aber Herr Hoce, MRT ist schwer in Deutschland und deswegen diese Computertomographie mit
Kontrastmittel anpassen ist. Und bei Billierer Genese ist eine ERCP eher verdammt.
Und dann eine Residiprophylaxie?
Was empfehlen Sie Kollegen?
Oh ja, ja, was empfängt Sie?
Meinen wegen den Steinen oder wegen dem Verschluss?
Kein Problem. Steinen und deswegen Residiprophylax.
Erst mal OP, dann andere.
Polizistik, Tommy, genau.
Gewicht 95 kg und 1,9 m.
Also die Menge Gewichtreduktion?
Ja, Gewichtreduktion.
Sehr gut.
Du bist eine Disziplin, du hast es auch gemacht.